here we go you may have seen the video
over the weekend we have this from The
Daily Mail Los Angeles Nike store robbed
as shoplifters hit Topanga Nordstrom
again
the latest in a troubling string of
violent Smash and grab incidents
there's a video going around
Nordstrom ransacked for a hundred
thousand dollars of the merchandise
they're not even covering their faces
anymore I saw a video of guys robbing a
supermarket
they didn't even wear a mask
just it's three dudes they walk in they
grab they felt their car walk out go to
the car and start filling up while the
guy films them there's a video of a
woman stealing from a store she just
throws it in her car jumps in her car
speeds off
this is what people don't get
Civil War or I should say Revolution or
social breakdown in many countries
especially the ones that I've seen
it is not like a bunch of people go
outside stand in front of a Podium and
say we the people of the Continental
Liberty faction hereby Proclaim it's
like a group of people run through a
building smashing up things and setting
fires for no reason and then in the
chaos people start to seize power power
shifts you get a bunch of people looting
and smashing and then when this spreads
too far and it spreads to political
areas the system breaks down when you've
got these Smash and grabs going on in at
this Nordstrom apparently it happened
again you know I don't know if you guys
have seen the video look at this guy
just filling up his bags being like
ain't nothing you can do about it cops
aren't going to do anything about it
well and if you were to get caught he'd
get released it's California right now
what happens to what does a regular
person think
run-of-the-mill law-abiding citizen says
what's the purpose of money why am I
following these rules like why not not I
don't think they say that I think
they're terrified that if they right now
the story is a man rapes a woman on a
train in Philadelphia and the question
is why didn't anyone save her well
because if you try to you go to prison
like when uh that dude in New York
stopped that guy threatening to kill
people they charge him with a crime
so now people are thinking
if you follow the law you go to jail
if you try to protect yourself you go to
jail and you don't need money to buy
anything because criminals don't go to
jail
I think more and more people are just
going to say these are the new rules
that's what's hap that's what seems like
is happening that's exactly we're gonna
live in fear right like you guys had a
different reaction than I did I would
say why would I still live here why
would I go to this Nordstrom if this is
what's happening I don't think they live
in fear before what I was going to say
before the show I was reading the story
about the 76 year old who got stabbed
when he in the on the New York subway
platform I think this was today because
he refused to give a panhandler money I
mean I think as social order breaks down
people become more conscious of the fact
that like your safety is not guaranteed
which of course you should always be
careful on the other hand
The increased number of stabbings on New
York City public transit is concerning
right did you see the video of the
there's two black guys holding an Asian
guy one one black guy's holding the
Asian guy so he can't move with his
arm's locked while the other guy just
winds up and smacks him in the face over
and over again
people just walk by and just videoed it
I don't understand people just watched
and filmed and they didn't do anything
about it it was a stop Asian hate thing
like those are going viral being Asian
in New York actually seems terrifying
honestly I feel like I see videos of
Asian guys and old old Asian people
getting just hauled off and just wrecked
by black guys up there
it's crazy
I'll say also with this uh La this whole
La a hundred thousand dollar thing I
wouldn't be shocked at all if this is
organized like there's got I think
there's Crim some criminal people out
there right now that see that people
don't get in trouble for stealing the
stuff and they go out there and they
organize large groups of people to go
take go steal this stuff mob ever that
would be a mafia then and maybe there is
a new Mafia That's created of just young
people that are stealing and
coordinating theft that would be a new
mafia then that would require Federal
attention yeah these gangs exactly yeah
we're too busy so I'll issue I'll show a
clarification on the story
the the viral video that was going
around because I didn't actually I just
Google searched it so apparently the guy
beating the guy being held claims the
Asian man he was beating was groping
women
hmm so great I love the destruction of
the the collapse of society that's all I
mean that you know I know like if that's
true then we have this random guy
groping women on a public subway
platform and even two guys get engaging
in vigilante justice to try and stop him
from doing it if that's even true that's
not true that means it's just like two
guys beating up this other guy like
either one not great for society does
not make me want to take the subway in
New York and this is why people just
don't they tune out they don't want to
look like stuff like this like this is
so complicated like we have no idea what
really happened here like these guys
might have just hold off and attacked
this dude that happens all the time in
New York this guy might have been
growing women if that happens all the
time in New York why am I you know the
farmer from Kansas gonna give you know a
rat's butt about this thing this is a is
a good example of the problem with why
people don't help anyone I just said a
guy a guy rapes a woman on a subway cart
in Philadelphia why does anyone help
because you pull the guy off you stop
him from doing it now you're on camera
beating up some guy and they're gonna
arrest you charge you and everyone's
gonna say they hate you for doing it
just like so earlier today my friend is
watching the video he goes look at this
and I passively see and I go wow I don't
even know what's going on and so I bring
it up here on the show I look it up and
I'm like the claim they made is that he
was trying to sexually assault a woman
so they grabbed and pulled him off and
then smacked him around here's my issue
with it you stop him from doing it then
you stand on a subway cart after you've
stopped it keep his arms locked and then
slap him repeatedly is still not a good
thing yeah
yeah yeah it's I mean I know you say
this whole time it like makes you want
to leave cities like if this is what's
happening you want to be far away from
people which I don't advocate for an
anti-social Society I think Community is
actually important but this is not
Community again you want to give credit
if someone is doing something like
stopping someone else from assaulting a
woman on the other hand do we even know
what happened we can't even trust
anything we hear because we're so used
to a warped media it's kind of
depressing honestly you just don't know
where to turn to wow I mean so so in the
video they've got them pinned they've
got them held back you can see this
they're holding him so he can't move
then one dude knocks him out slaps him
in the head knocking him out then the
other guy starts bashing punching him in
the head several times oh they went way
too far don't care what he was doing
you knocked him out and then you beat
his head on the ground like what the
hell I'll tell you this this is what
happens in societal breakdown you get a
story of a guy raping him on a train and
no one does anything and then you get
guys like this who see a guy going after
women and then they beat the crap out of
him it's like it's like I was saying
with the uh I bring up all the time with
Viva Vendetta when the inspector says
eventually someone will do something
stupid and it shows the finger man the
cop shoot the little girl and then all
of the locals walk up to him with bats
and crowbars and then it's heavily
implied they beat him I don't like
Vengeance and I when I asked I asked on
Twitter I was like okay just ask him for
a friend is Jesus Christ into Vengeance
just asking for eight billion people and
a lot of the Christians you know I want
the Christians to say out loud was
Christ your savior into Vengeance does
he suggest you create Vengeance on your
Foe and people are like no God does but
not Jesus but some people say Jesus is
God so yes it was very confusing but
then there's a question of what's the
difference between Vengeance and Justice
like obviously if someone commits a
horrific crime they there should be
justice but Justice doesn't always imply
punishment so I I don't know I don't
think revenge and seeking out after the
threat has been neutralized to go make
your emotions on that guy like that just
doesn't I don't I do not that is a
repetitive cycle that will grind us into
the dust so we've got to be careful not
to fall into it
I think it's all breaking down
this is what happens during the
breakdown and then eventually people
don't feel safe on the subway trains
eventually things are going to get a bit
worse than this we had the video of the
guys in Stockton beating the guy with a
with a stick now that guy we know for
sure on camera threatened to kill the
store clerks and so they grabbed him and
then started attacking him what do you
do to subdue a guy who he pulled out
some kind of weapon does he have a knife
or something did I get a knife and like
yeah that kills you one knife to the
chest you die and so they start hitting
him and all they had was a stick and
then the guy just cried then there's
more there's more photos I guess body
camera footage showing the guy in the
ground just being like they stopped
eventually the cops came and got him
they announced they would not be
charging these guys but I wonder I
wonder if this can reverse itself in in
the sense that a culture starts to
emerge where people will
just say we don't care what happens the
cops are going to deal with it and
they'll start attacking the criminals
well we're so just there's so much stuff
going on New York's so big like a place
like this you're so desensitized with
the internet I think all you can really
do is like those guys just be with
yourself protect yourself make sure
you're ready make sure you can protect
your family make sure you can protect
those around you that you care about
because we're getting the point and
that's I guess that that is the
destruction of a community because you
only care about the singular and that in
that scenario but all you can really do
out here these days especially like I
live in DC people are crazy like the
rant that guy from Rand Paul staffer got
stabbed I don't know if you guys have
seen that video yeah that's crazy he was
just walking down the street
yeah and just stabbed it for no reason
there was I can't remember which
congressman was who a guy followed her
into her apartment elevator and like she
threw coffee on him and like he was sort
of attacking her like this stuff is
happening all the time and of course we
hear about it more and more connected
people are connected to someone in the
public space but uh can you imagine just
being one of the runner Mill one of the
mill people who gets attacked on the
street you have to make a report to the
cops and cops are like I know crazy
right people are getting stabbed all the
time yeah we were just watching before
the shows uh footage from the Rodney
King riots in Los Angeles and it was
like Asian store owners she just walking
outside and shooting at random Korean
Korean Korean thank you uh shooting at
random people or people that they
thought were threatening their store I
don't know if those people ever got
arrested and charged but we're in the
age now of social media so we've got
this technocratic oversight that's like
like it's it's a temp it seems like it's
trying to criminalize self-defense like
Daniel Penny apparently choked out some
bum that was threatening to kill or hurt
a bunch of people on a train so he
choked him out and then he got he got
arrested for it like he defended those
people and then he's the one that got in
trouble the that wouldn't have happened
in the early 90s that didn't happen in
the 80s when we didn't have social media
where people get to sit and think for
like a week watch the video over and
over should we go after that guy should
we go should we should we they they
mentioned on Wikipedia that no rioters
were fatally shot by any of the Korean
volunteers the interesting thing is they
point out that because South Korea has a
two-year mandatory military service all
these guys had had Firearms experience
so they were warding them off with their
warning shots but they were firing
right like they have experience handling
no they're not someone who just bought a
gun because they're scared and they
don't know how to use it you could argue
that wasn't even I mean that wasn't even
self-defense at that point because
they're defending their store maybe but
I didn't the people weren't near the
store that they were shooting at I
didn't see any people on cameras just
dudes out in front shooting like in diff
around not so much the point the point
is this technocratic March towards
communism is making us look at ourselves
hypercritically and criminalize
self-defense we've got to stop doing
that to ourselves we have to let
self-defense Reign you need to be able
to defend yourself in your community or
the community will fall you have to do
that
I think it's interesting what you said
how you we watched that clip hundreds of
times over and over again because if you
think if you've been in like a fight
before or any kind of like physical
altercation it's quick it's not like
you're sitting there and you're deciding
your next move like your Sherlock Holmes
in that movie like you're trying to sit
there and you're surviving you're
reacting and so people like they see
they gauge like oh I wouldn't have
choked him for that long I was like well
I'm holding on that guy for dear life
you know like stuff like that you have
no idea he could get up and kill you
yeah that's the thing about the the guy
the Sikhs in Stockton who are beating
the guy with the stick and there are
some people being like yeah but they
they kept going and he was begging and
crying and it's like and he could kill
them he pulled some kind of weapon and
threatened them to with death and he had
threatened to shoot them in the past
that's that was reported uh in previous
stories and they're not trained it's not
like they're police officers it's not
like they're Jiu Jitsu fighters on the
ground to go wrestle this guy's knife
away like have you seen the video of the
guy who executes I think was a 7-Eleven
clerk yeah he walks behind the counter
he's pointing the gun at him the guy's
on his ground on the ground his knees
just with his hands up the guy opens it
just takes the money looks at him shoots
him in the head and then grabs the money
just walks out casually and so we built
this system where we're supposed to tell
victims just sit there and hope you
don't die but you might that's insane
didn't some uh maybe it was a different
clerk in like New Yorker 7-Eleven did he
stab someone or shoot somebody that came
into the store that was attacking yeah
yeah
what was that story a guy a woman a
woman got mad because the potato chips
cost too much money or something like
that told her boyfriend the boyfriend
came in started uh hitting the store
clerk and she pulls out a knife they
fight he grabs the knife from her stabs
the guy who was beating him the guy I
guess he died is that what happened or
no he went to the he didn't die I don't
I don't know if he might they arrested
the store clerk and sent him to Rikers
yeah whoa and then all along for murder
first assault or something and then only
after major outcry did he get released
yeah those guys with the stick could
easily and like if they're in the wrong
place wrong time wrong D.A like we're
talking about the Trump stuff right now
I guess that kind of comes or if no one
caught it on video right like there are
people who are in the right to defend
themselves who don't get the kind of
public outcry that that guy got you're
dependent on someone else advocating for
you it's just crazy it feels so obvious
I don't know if this is true it feels
like foreign governments and foreign
corporations I'm talking about the world
economic Forum talking about the CCP God
knows the Russian government's involved
are trying to get the United States to
fail it's they want us to hurt each
other and to die and and they would love
for us to criminalize our own defensive
capabilities so why would you let that
happen
why think about it
yeah I mean I think you're right I think
people do want to see America fail and
that's why people have to be conscious
of what's going on around them
I I don't know how to help I don't know
how to help besides making some Grand
sacrifice well all you can do is like
work on in your small community where
your friends are like and try to make
sure that they're safe they're healthy
they're working hard they have a good
Avenue to get out of the stuff and I
think about like I used to be a little
bit more like what are we going to do
full Rebel like that's not gonna that's
not gonna work out like maybe it does
maybe we have to maybe that's what
ultimately it's gonna happen but what
you can focus on when stuff is going on
like this is make sure you're armed make
sure you're healthy make sure you have a
good food supply like make sure you know
how to farm you know how to hunt that's
on I have friends that I've never held a
gun like I've never shot a gun before
like what if it all does go bad and we
have to start hunting and fishing and
stuff like that at least I was raised
that way because I'm from the south like
I can't imagine some of these Yankee
guys up in New York like what are they
gonna do like can't go to the because
like can't go to the Gazebo up there you
know or the true yeah yeah there's
nothing like I mean you you make a
lifestyle Choice when you are choosing
to live in certain cities in certain
States and I get that but I think
there's a lack of long-term thinking you
know I think right now people are
thinking well New York City's beautiful
and great and there are lots of
wonderful things about cities in the
country uh cities across the country
it's just the state of them right now
you have to be conscious of the choice
that you're making if you're what you're
choosing to live in yeah we've been
living too fat for too long I think too
I think it's part that's part of it
America's been on top for too long yeah
we're getting soft we don't we never we
don't have to do the conflicts I know
that not that many people have thought
like you were saying earlier in those
battles and like I guess that so people
say maybe not everybody fought back then
but I think that we had some hard
choices that we haven't had to have in a
while and we're now we're facing yeah we
need to prepare for war every one of us
and that's so it doesn't happen we need
to know how to fire a gun we need to
know
it's we're on a kid-friendly show right
and Ian started working out for this
music video and he's getting more and
more conservative that that study was
right I was watching videos about on the
ancient Romans and how they would
conquer capua for instance their
southern neighbors there's a bunch of
farmers they didn't know how to fight
because they lived their whole lives as
just Farmers living off the land and
then when the mountain men came in they
knew how to fight and they were the ones
that took the land so if we don't know
how to fight we're basically these fat
Farmers waiting to be taken and it's not
like that stuff doesn't happen anymore
it's not like these there aren't
hardened Warriors out there that want
our stuff we need we need to be prepared
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time